while a number of talented actors have
given us their own takes on Gotham's
Clown Prince of Crime it's what we don't
know about the character that makes his
presence so intriguing and terrifying
some fans have tried to fill in those
gaps themselves and the results are both
absurd and horrifying much like the
Joker himself hi Jerry
Tim Burton's 1989 Batman and not only
heralded a new era in well-made serious
comic book movies but it also offered a
major reimagining of a huge part of the
Caped Crusader mythos the events that
sent Bruce Wayne on the path to becoming
Batman the night his parents were robbed
and killed by an otherwise petty
criminal named Joe Chill in the world of
the 89 cinematic Batman however the
Joker is responsible for the ignoble end
of Thomas and Martha Wayne that reveal
only increased Bruce Wayne's loathing of
the Joker which motivated him to stop
this criminal menace and helped elevate
the Joker to arch-villain status or per
one fan theory pertaining specifically
to Burton's Batman what if the Joker was
the same Joker from most other Berman
media and wasn't the guy who killed the
Wayne's adherence to this theory say
that since Batman is so obviously mental
and emotionally tortured he projects
blame for the death of his parents on to
the Joker because that's the guy he's
fighting the Dark Knight's merely
planted the Joker connection into his
memory in order to explain his own
hatred for the guy you think you might
greatest enemy yes you're obsessed with
me no I'm not yes you are no I'm not
well some theories seem to balance on
the fine line between fan fiction and
Canon others are a little more out there
strap in kiddies cuz we're in for a
bumpy ride
remember that adorably creepy kid in the
shining well he wound up being the main
character in Stephen King's sequel dr.
sleep if that came out in 2013 a full
five years after the Dark Knight in 2008
so some funds developed an alternative
theory what if Danny Torrance grew up to
be the Joker one anonymous meme creator
postulated just that using the first of
Joker's many stated origins as evidence
my father
was a drinker and will nine he goes off
crazier than usual mommy gets the
kitchen knife to defend herself he
doesn't like that
now we're not seriously arguing that the
Dark Knight was meant to be a sequel to
The Shining but maybe Christopher
Nolan's interpretation of the character
was partially inspired by the 1980s ik
Nolan is a huge fan of shining director
Stanley Kubrick so much so he helped
restore Kubrick's 2001 a Space Odyssey
and there's precedent as Jack
Nicholson's performance as Jack Torrance
did help secure him the role of the
Joker in 1989's Batman
so hey anything's possible right King
hanged he looks like the Joker he acts
like the Joker and the movies named
after the Joker but I calling to some
fans
Joaquin Phoenix isn't playing the Joker
and Joker at least not the Joker we all
know and love
for starters feeding stars playing a
character named Arthur Fleck well we've
heard Joker's name is Jack Napier before
most notably in Tim Burton's Batman as
well as Batman the Animated Series he's
never had a single what a hundred
percent canonical origin story and
except for all the Joker trappings the
character of Arthur Fleck is a whole new
creation when you bring me out can you
introduce me as Joker some fans are
theorized that the Joker
Arthur becomes isn't the Joker that
Batman fans know at all and that is
taking on the name of Joker is a big red
herring mr. Fleck is also several
decades older than the boy who would
become Batman Phoenix is in his 40s
while Dante Pereira Olsen who has been
cast as young Bruce Wayne is very young
indeed making it impossible to imagine
these two growing up to have any kind of
rivalry this has caused fans to
speculate that Phoenix's Arthur Fleck is
not the real Joker but his clownish
criminal predecessor who inspires the
true Joker years later others have
floated a different theory that Arthur's
Joker just doesn't age or diet or
despite its sometimes realistic take on
crime
Batman still is about an oddly dressed
billionaire vigilante who tracks down
weirdo theatrical villains like a guy in
a question mark covered one piece and an
umbrella wielding penguin man in other
words it also wouldn't be completely
absurd if the Joker everybody's favorite
crazed criminal clown turns out to be
immortal but don't take our word for it
this is actually something that's been
explored in the comics
according to Batman issue 37 released in
2014 as part of the endgame arc the
Joker can and will live forever in the
comic Commissioner Gordon uncovers old
newspaper photos depicting the Joker
committing crimes in 1910 and 1946 he
assumes the Joker doctored the photos
but after the Joker in Jaws a seemingly
fatal gunshot blast it would seem that
trickster is telling the truth by the
end of endgame of both Batman and the
Joker lay dead but then maybe the Joker
just wants everybody to think he's dead
since that's definitely a mistake Gotham
City has made before I think you and I
are destined to do this forever check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos but your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the bail so you don't miss a single one
[Music]